you know i was thinking about like when
we grow up you know kids usually have
like this idea i want to be a doctor i
want to be a
you know a fireman i want to be whatever
i remember
as a kid i didn't think anything other
than i don't think i'm going to get
through
eighth grade i don't think i'm not
kidding i thought there's no way i'm
gonna live through high school i mean i
just
had this it wasn't like a death wish or
maybe it was it wasn't like i was a
suicidal kid i just felt like i'm not
gonna make it i'm not gonna i didn't
have aspirations of really doing
anything until
i guess late in high school i started to
think you know i don't know maybe i
could act i don't know i
honestly thought i was going to pump gas
or work in a grocery store
or you know because i worked in the
grocery store for three years and it
just seemed like the thing to do
and you know luck and all this other
[ __ ] happened after i
ended up going to college but for you
did you what were you thinking as a kid
because at 19 you're already going to
wrestling school so i assume when you
were young you
thought you were athletic you were in a
sports how did it all happen man
yeah like i just uh when i was a kid i
had this
mindset where i wanted to be um
i wanted to be a wrestler and i wanted
to be in a rock and roll band in fact i
remember i remember
thinking but like literally kind of
deciding that very early on maybe 13 or
14 or something like that because it
just seemed like those were
because those were my two favorite
things in hockey but i wasn't very good
at hockey
uh and i just didn't like the team
element of hockey i liked kind of the
personalities and uh kind of the
spotlight and the characters
you know both in wrestling and in rock
and roll as well so those are that's
kind of like well
those seem like two things that would be
fun to do
and i never really understood whenever
you know someone would ask me especially
when i you know was 16 17 years old
telling me you know i'm going to go into
wrestling and people kind of laugh kind
of thing you'd be like
saying you wanted to be a mime or a sore
swallower in the circus it's like what
especially back then like 1990 it wasn't
as open as it is now where
you can go online and find out like oh
here's where you go to a wrestling
school
and here's the secrets of the trade or
whatever it's very
closed society how do you do that when
you're you know
17 18 years old growing up in the
prairies of canada so
um but but i just kind of got those
those thoughts into my head at least it
gave me a direction
and a vision like i have three teenage
kids right now and
they might kind of know what they want
to do but not really
but for me i knew like this is what i'm
going to do i just have to figure out
how the [ __ ] i'm going to do it
but there's no other option so once i
kind of had that
that mindset and that direction at least
it gave me something to shoot for
and a goal to try and reach